women are wearing the pants a lot more
than men now we are built want to guide
a family and once that gets challenged
and challenged and challenged they want
to please their women so they think if I
say yes I will make her happy to an
extent I understand the logic in that
but women actually are built to
challenge a man's authority to test him
are you a suitable mate how strong are
you in standing your ground with respect
it can build something stronger where
she will respect you more you just have
to be willing to withstand that moment
of difficulty but it will actually send
you down a much better path as a
relationship and the amount of men who
miss that opportunity early on and I see
them later on where they're like taking
their wife's name of the aisle
practically they might as well be
throwing the bouquet over their shoulder
sometimes I do want to give them a shake
and go [__] helmet stand up
the true Geordie podcast